I don't know how he's skinny people do
this yet my friend curly told me his
resolution this year is to get in shape
except he hates working out but good
news is I love working out so I'm gonna
help him out
hey curly hey so you don't like working
out but we're gonna figure out what you
do like okay would you rather be inside
or outside uh in sight alone or with a
group of people I say alone but I don't
mind like one other person or so would
you say that you're like an intense
person or more chill
I say more chill I hate when like you
make that ugly face when you're getting
really into it and I don't want to make
that ugly face okay okay I think this is
gonna be easy
I'll call you later okay I figured out
something I think curly might like so I
told him to get changed and meet me at
my apartment
it was sunny without fit that's all I
have to wear I think I've created a
workout that you might not hate I'm
scared don't be scared you're gonna be
fine let's make this ridiculous hey
we're gonna do 10 push-ups okay
wearing a 20 squat does 20 split squats
do 10 on each leg then we're gonna do 30
of the glute bridges okay we're into a
40 second plank 50 jumping jacks and
then 60 seconds of rest 50 in a row yeah
and then do it again we're gonna do it
again at least one more time maybe two
more times
are you excited not really you should be
this is what I who I don't like working
out it's like you have to be very
vulnerable and very okay with looking
ridiculous
can you hear my heartbeat how do people
not throw up when they workout because
sometimes they throw up what never we
are
going crazy should is giving you a brief
reading I'm like not even present
anymore I'm like in my brain honestly
though that's the part I like about
working out so you just let your body do
its thing
this is like a really good workout but I
haven't had a very long
I'll be a'ight
50 whoo now we get to rest again for a
minute
you know you're my favorite ice-cream to
get that mean are you okay can I steal
makeup on make one corner on teen drama
writing drama writing whoa we're done so
would you do it again yeah actually I
love it it's great I feel really good I
said from my back to my table my desk
and be like yeah productive today yeah
thank you so much thanks for working out
on me Jordan I'm glad you didn't hate it
no I loved it in for success I'm going
with your work here's the thing most
people who tell you they like working
out don't like it because they like
being exhausted and sweaty and tired
they like it because of how they feel
after so don't be discouraged if it's
hard it's supposed to be hard you just
have to find something that you don't
totally hate doing and it'll feel like a
cool challenge instead of like a
punishment
you